it's a big moment this is a big moment
because you could change history tonight
have you have you thought that through
and what it will mean not only to your
country but international cinema if you
can walk away with Best Picture what is
going on in your mind to come up with a
movie like that because it is original
it is interesting it's also crazy as
hell because I'm the other that's right
now how many people have already
contacted you about remaking it in
different languages HBO series a room
and a limited edition Mandira katemel an
atomic item and NASA atom making NJ
critical today what we going in on
director chick Motegi or two adjectives
and garage more Jong hazing dozen
optimum check ok we know that we're
still in the very early stages
congratulations and last thing what time
is it in Korea and will everybody be up
losing their mind for this thing this
morning time this morning at 9:30 are
their parties going on the only time
drinking maybe yeah is he going out live
to Korea mr. Boogedy Tony Seeman good
luck and congratulations you crazy
[Laughter]
[Music]